ich will nicht
ich kann nicht aber wir machen es
trotzdem hinter green day
doch die brauchen
als
start war direkt richtig qualitativ
hochwertig marschner einfach der
equitystory ag
diese plattform enttäuscht mich wirklich
nicht kommt ein bisschen kommen werden
müsse
habe ich diese serie
ich
bild nicht mehr
[Musik]
ein herzinfarkt dir selber denkt ich
würde nie einen freund finde ich werde
nie eine freundin finden keiner mag mich
die eine sache du bist nur single weil
du noch mal herzlich
kann nur das wiederholen was ich zu
beginn gesagt habe ich will dieses video
nicht aufnehme ich kann dieses video
nicht aufnehmen aber ich mache es
trotzdem und vielleicht kommen ja jetzt
so was qualitativ hochwertigem auf
diesem schild steht hier ist kein
hundeklo ein glück dass ich keinen hund
ging
wer hat euch allen zielen geschlossen
china oder dem ex box im handel haben
als ich in die ernst ich bin raus ich
glaub ich
wirklich überhaupt nichts gegen eine
gesangs kills ich kann selber
besser aber du singst in einen kopfhörer
[Musik]
ja jetzt machen wir mal dem fest war
damit dieses wunderschöne glas ist eine
schönster hätte ich es klasse was testet
der da ein energy drink an machen wir
mal auf warum sagst du die ganze zeit
war die ente von deinen weg sind es
zischt und kribbelt und krabbelt klar
was macht ein getränk noch unterricht
und löst ein energydrink zucht globe it
und rist
mach weiter es riecht nach das ganze
stadt gießen wer kennt nicht freunde
wenn das getränk einfach mal ganz stark
nach diesem blau riecht aber hammer
geruch hier kann man auch gleich sehen
dass es ist schmutzig oder 50 hat ja
meine lieben freunde hier kann man ganz
genau sehen es scheint sich oder
vermutlich ab ich habe auch hier wieder
keine ahnung was du damit meint ist kann
es
wir wären ja ja
erklärt entsteht und ich scheiß auf
alles dieses 6000 kalorien chips wieder
habe ich in eine minute
[Musik]
können wir nicht ein video mit qualität
haben
in etwa mit solcher qualität wie dieses
kissen war sein erster 56 - dieses
wundervolle hellblau beziehungsweise
bunte pailletten kissen wird am ersten
sechs und 15 00 uhr shop.de launischen
es wird nur 2000 stück davon limitiert
gebnis zu jeder bestellung erhaltet ihr
eine selbstverständlich von mir
persönlich handsignierte autogrammkarte
ich hoffe wir sehen uns am ersten sechs
im buchshop ich kann gar nicht auf wenn
damit das ist viel zu nahe
[Musik]
du bist wie ihr wisst bescheid wenn sich
dann kommt mein referat ich werde heute
in refrath darüber halten wie die
glühbirne erfunden wurde ja auch muss
ich jetzt zum kampfsport
ich war schon gestern da soll ich jetzt
wirklich schon gespurt
ich habe dieses video finde ich wirklich
zu einer prozent zwar nicht so dass ich
an der bushaltestelle sitze unter
telefon schrei ja ich war kamen sport
aber wenn ich beispielsweise durch die
innenstadt laufen leute auf entfernung
sehe den ich jetzt nicht unbedingt hallo
sagen will dann zügig immer so als wenn
ich telefonieren wird und dann sage ich
ja was hast du mit kamel
nicht schlecht ich habe beruflich
kellner glaube ich kann mir pflegealltag
erzählt also seife nicht die einmal hin
zu kamel klägers mich genauso wie bei
sportlern nicht kamel produkt das ist
ganz normales pro dose auf kamelen stadt
fern gibt's richtig oft wirklich es
eigentlich voll korrekt es gibt doch
irgendwo kamel polo und kann mir pflege
braucht man auch
in jeder folge
dort user denke ich mir jetzt müssen wir
noch mal den tiefpunkt erreicht haben
doch dann setzt er immer noch sitzen die
leute immer noch einen drauf
[Musik]
what is it hat wild hog 1 1 aus wie ein
m und m
[Musik]
alle die diesen insider nicht kennen
denken sich nur warum lässt du dir
diesen zeiten eine mundharmonika
ja
auf zwei arten von fußballfans der seine
mannschaft anfeuern
freiburg die ultras frankfurt vor noch
ein tor
mein lieber pizza von 1 gegend wie habe
ich dort absolut kein unterschied
entdeckt
[Musik]
denn ich
das meinen dad oder meinung
sagen würde würde mich kopfüber fuß nach
irgendwie einfach mal einen klopapier
automaten gefunden und wir werden uns
jetzt auf jeden fall was bestellen mal
sehen wie das geht bitte sprechen sie
laut und deutlich wie ich gerne einmal
klopapier zum mitnehmen bitte werfen sie
mache ich das jetzt wird königin abholen
gut dank der oma sagt geklappt ihre
warum bekomme ich sowas empfohlen und
ich freue mich in der kasse nach einem
ausrüster hat wirklich keinen ausweis
dabei und die holt dann so eine anti
kassiererin sation und sagt sie ja wie
alt die auch und ich mache so meinen
super konter von meiner jacke immer so
meint anzuzeigen frag mich nicht wieso
ich dachte es eine gute idee aber ich
habe vergessen dass ich unter die werke
gar nichts drunter hatte weil es mein t
shirt als mundschutz benutzt hab ich
vergessen habe man ja mal garnicht an
guckt mich an diesen beim bier ist
ich weiß nicht
ob er überhaupt nicht mehr zu retten
sein
komplett am arsch
da beides
aber gut
bis zum letzten takt of video und das
ist ein tipp an alle die ein date haben
und kein bock mehr auf das date haben ja
das wird nichts besonderes damals unser
zuhause kommt ja jetzt sofort keine
ahnung warum
sie meinte nur dass es dringend ja da
sagte ich auf und dann wiederholt sich
das video weil er auf tik tok seit und
dann hat er ordentlich am arsch an der
stelle wird er heute hier trifft
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
da schreibt mir euren namen und in die
kommentare ich heiße dort laser luca
aber auch ein neues ticket video
hochgeladen was sich allerdings heute
leider nicht zeigen konnte weil ich
daran nicht die rechte habe allerdings
befinden wir uns jetzt auch schon im
auto hier findet ihr immer in zwei die
eingeblendet wenn du noch kein teil der
luxus sei der community von meinem kanal
ein klick darauf dadurch könnt ihr
kostenlos einen kanal abonnieren
verpasst keine videos mehr und hier ist
ein video verlinkt was du eben auf
meinem 2 kanal online gegangen ist
[Musik]